you don't have to wait much longer for  Dark Souls 3 but if you're really  itching for more if there's more footage  out there developer from software  recently streams some gameplay from the  wall of low duluth area showing off some  of those fancy new weapon arts first up  was the longsword which lets you pierce  through enemy defenses with a ready  stance then there's the scimitars which  can be used in a graceful spinning  attack in the air and on the ground the  great sword is certainly less graceful  but it can send your enemies flying into  the air with a launching attack finally  the mace seems to be able to boost your  defense that you come in handy in many  fights dark souls 3 comes to ps4 xbox  one and pc on march 24th then we'll  finally get to test out all those weapon  arts for ourselves in the meantime stick  with gamespot for all the Dark Souls  news you could need